hey youtubers is charlie i'm recording
this video from my new apartment I'm
just happy that it all didn't get
smashed in the move but Gemma Whelan was
talking about coming back for Game of
Thrones Season 6 we know they're doing
some Ironborn stuff so I thought it'd be
fun to do video talking about that a new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far now
you're is a pretty interesting character
a lot of you know that they changed her
from the books in the books she's called
Asha Greyjoy on the show they called her
Yara just so casual viewers wouldn't
confuse her with OSHA you know
completely different character now since
they've been filming season six we know
that they cast you're on Greyjoy he's
coming on the show one of Yara's uncles
and it looks like the show probably
isn't going to be doing Victarion her
other uncle who kind of goes hand in
hand with your on but more than any
other family the line of succession is a
big deal for the Greyjoy's the Seastone
chair now Balon Greyjoy rules right now
as far as we know Theon is the next in
line but he has completely jumped off
the deep end he's reek right now so for
all intents and purposes Yara is the
next in line to succeed Balan the first
time we met her on the show Theo Theon
got a little bit handsy she explained a
lot of the hardships she endured trying
to gain the respect of the men attaining
a place of power especially in their
father's eyes who as you can tell from
the way he treats Theon is a total
he almost makes Tywin look like
a really nice guy so it becomes pretty
clear from early on that Yara is someone
who desires power she desires leadership
so we're something to happen to ballad
you think that she would get the
Seastone chair by rights but based on
what we know about season 6 it seems
like Theon is headed back in that
direction so what would happen if he
were to show up at the Iron Islands he's
completely unfit to rule right now but
the other Ironborn might rally behind
him because the Seastone chair is his by
rights even though technically Yara
would be more fit to rule now throw your
on into the mix he is a much more
powerful person much more well-traveled
much more respected in the eyes of his
people he could also potentially assert
his right to rule this is where we get
into Kingsmoot territory now the
Kingsmoot is an ancient Ironborn
ceremony whereby all the long ship
captains choose their next leader it's a
lot like a great council in Westeros the
Lords of Westeros can meet to decide who
gets to be
the next king if they want their they've
only been a couple great councils in
history Kingsmoot also relatively rare
but a very big deal especially if
there's a question of succession now
this is where we get into big changes
from the books season 6 gonna change a
lot of things from the books that
includes things in and around the Iron
Islands because it seems like Stannis
Baratheon is dead and he gets tied up
with your story line at a certain point
so if that's not going to be happening
and they're not going to do Victarion
who's also a big part of that they're
probably just going to simplify what's
going on with the Iron Islands but the
biggest part of that will be the
question of succession like what are
they going to do with Theon if he's
supposed to be the next in line to take
the Seastone chair but he is unfit to
roll even though they haven't done a
whole lot with yards character on the
show I feel like this would be her
season to shine a lot of people credit
Game of Thrones for their strong women
Yara is one of those people so naturally
seeing her struggle to take leadership
of the Iron Islands could be something
that's very interesting obviously the
books do something very very different
so you guys can let me know like if even
if you haven't read the books do you
think that you're up for all the stuff
that we've seen her do is capable of
taking the Seastone chair even if it
belongs to Theon technically even if
he's next in line and even if Theon is
headed back to the Iron Islands what do
you think that they would do I mean are
they just gonna sit around and try to
figure out what to do next or are they
gonna turn right back around and try to
attack the north again there's already
so many armies brewing in the North you
have the Bolton's then you have the
North remembers storyline so you have
the North collectively rallying to get
rid of the Bolton's so the Ironborn were
to try to come back with their own
interest in the North then they would
probably get smashed it either way it's
definitely going to be a really
interesting season for Yara jimoh
weiland the actress said that she's
headed back to the area where they film
a lot of those things where she's filled
a lot of scenes in the past up in
Ireland so hopefully she won't just get
pushed to the side for yer on because I
know you're on is a very exciting
character for a lot of different reasons
with it without getting into book
spoilers but as we saw with the door and
characters you know sometimes when they
bring new characters on the show they'll
push pre-existing characters to the side
a little like I felt like even even
Jamie's story line Jamie Ghana got
pushed to the side in his own storyline
just so they can focus more on the
Dornish characters but let me know like
what do you guys really want to see from
the Ironborn storyline I think we all
want to see the Kingsmoot but that's not
something that they would stretch out
over 10 episodes like that that was
probably something they would come
which within like one or two episodes I
know a lot of you guys have been asking
like when is the trailer going to come
what are they going to start doing
promotional material they are shooting
stuff on set people are doing interviews
with the cast so we might see some
pictures by the end of the year /
typically trailers don't drop till the
spring HBO has a new series called
westworld that's coming so they might
use that to promote Game of Thrones
depending on when West world ends up
airing they kind of did that back when
true detective season 1 1st air just
because that series preceded Game of
Thrones so they aired a lot of promos
during true detective but in related
news there's a whole bunch of stuff
happening like Supergirl is airing
tonight Gotham is back so I'm gonna try
to get videos app for everything I might
not get a Supergirl video out till later
in the week you just follow me on
Twitter and Facebook for updates on when
videos are gonna post and I still need
to build my studio out just like a
little bit just to fix the sound so if i
send a little bit weird in this video
just because the space where i'm
recording is just a little bit empty
right now why you guys wait for me to
finish building everything out and do it
like a room tour video and all that
stuff you can click here for all my Game
of Thrones season 6 videos and you can
click here for last night's episode of
walking dead major major WTF the end so
be sure to be sure to watch the episode
before you watch the video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you